Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Les batailles écologiques à venir.
Les conflits se multiplient
sur la planète.
Guerre en Ukraine et ailleurs,
au Proche-Orient,
en Afrique, et partout
où le terrorisme et le nationalisme
se nourrissent
de la radicalisation religieuse
des esprits
et de l'intolérance politique.
Mais il est des conflits
qui ne disent pas leur nom
et qui nourrissent l'égoïsme
et la compétition effrénée
des nations. Les guerres écologiques
autour de l'accès à l'eau,
de la sécurité
et de la souveraineté alimentaire et
de l'approvisionnement énergétique.
Dans ce domaine,
qu'on pourrait qualifier
d'écostratégique, tout se tient
en vérité, car comment dissocier
le cycle de l'eau
de la production d'énergie
et de l'industrie agroalimentaire
comme de la consommation
des aliments
dans la mesure où les interférences
avec le climat,
l'économie,
la préservation de l'environnement,
la stabilité des sociétés
et la paix des nations
sont étroitement imbriquées.
Par ailleurs,
face au gaspillage consumériste,
au risque
de pénurie
et aux catastrophes naturelles,
la notion de sobriété
s'est imposée,
au même titre
qu'un accès équitable et partagé
aux ressources et aux innovations
de progrès. Nous allons
en parler avec mes invités
que je vous présente. Jean Jouzel,
vous êtes paléoclimatologue du GIEC,
vous avez même obtenu le prix Nobel
alors que vous étiez
directeur scientifique,
et vous êtes directeur de recherche
au CEA.
Madame Sandrine Rousseau,
vous êtes députée de Paris,
Ecologie et NUPES.
Magali
Reghezza-Zitt,
vous êtes maître de conférence
en géographie
à l'Ecole normale supérieure.
Emmanuelle Galichet,
vous êtes enseignante-chercheuse
au CNAM.
Et Jean de Kervasdoué,
vous êtes économiste de la santé
et ancien directeur des hôpitaux.
-Vous venez de voir deux citations,
l'une de Régis Debray, "Chimène n'a
plus d'yeux pour les prolétaires
"mais pour les ruminants."
Et une citation du comédien
Philippe Torreton,
"Les appels citoyens se heurtent
à l'inertie mortifère
"de nos dirigeants."
On va commencer par là.
Est-ce qu'on serait passé de
la primauté sociale à l'injonction
écologique ? Les avis sont
partagés. Mais quel est
votre sentiment sur la gouvernance
écologique de la planète
et la passivité supposée
de nos dirigeants,
qu'en pensez-vous, Jean Jouzel ?
-D'abord, je crois
qu'en termes, disons, d'écologie,
de transition écologique,
il faut revenir
aux aspects scientifiques.
C'est une réalité. C'est une
nécessité. On ne peut pas imaginer
un monde dans lequel la neutralité
carbone ne serait pas atteinte.
Alors, je crains que ce soit trop
tard pour limiter le réchauffement
à 1 degré, 1,5 degré,
mais ne pas atteindre
la neutralité carbone,
c'est accepter l'idée
que le climat
se réchauffe indéfiniment.
Il faut bien comprendre
que donc, d'abord, ça s'appuie
sur une réalité scientifique.
D'un autre côté, nous avons eu
effectivement, du côté
de la communauté scientifique,
des difficultés
à faire passer cette idée
de la nécessité d'une transition
à la fois vers le grand public,
vers nos dirigeants,
bien que
la Convention Climat de 92
fixe comme objectif
de stabiliser
le réchauffement climatique.
Ce n'est qu'à Paris
qu'on parle d'une stabilisation
avec un objectif chiffré.
Voilà l'accord de Paris.
Donc c'est tout cela,
la démarche.
Bon, il y a eu quand même
du côté des dirigeants,
et j'aime bien le dire,
une prise en compte
du message du GIEC en ce sens,
par exemple, qu'on parle
de neutralité carbone
à horizon 2050.
Plus d'une centaine de pays
l'ont inscrit dans leurs objectifs.
Le problème, c'est que ce n'est
que dans les textes.
Il y a un fossé entre ce qui est
inscrit dans les textes,
y compris en France,
et la réalité.
C'est ça le vrai problème.
Donc oui, je crois qu'on a essayé
en tant que communauté
de faire passer nos idées,
on y arrive, ça prend du temps.
Nous sommes désormais...
Le mot clé du 6e rapport du GIEC
est le mot certitude.
Nous sommes certains que l'ensemble
ou quasiment l'ensemble
du réchauffement
est lié aux activités humaines,
certains que nous allons
vers un réchauffement,
qu'il risque d'être important
si nous n'y prenons pas garde.
On part plutôt vers 3 degrés.
C'est tout cela notre discours,
enfin, notre discours,
notre constat, je dirais, il y a
une écoute, mais on est loin
entre l'écoute
et, disons, la réalité.
-Sandrine Rousseau,
on a entendu
la position scientifique.
Pensez-vous
que les dirigeants en font pas assez
ou en font trop ? Et lesquels ?
-Déjà, actons
qu'ils n'en font pas assez.
Puisque là, on est
sur une trajectoire de 3 degrés,
les chances que l'on reste
en deçà de 1,5 sont...
s'affaiblissent
et fondent comme neige au soleil.
Ce qui me frappe vraiment énormément
depuis que je suis à l'Assemblée,
j'ai l'habitude de dire
que je n'ai jamais été
aussi écoanxieuse que depuis
que j'y suis. En fait, ce qui
me frappe, c'est le déni complet,
complet, qu'il y a
de la représentation nationale
sur la question climatique.
On gère la question
climatique éventuellement
dans une loi sur l'énergie ou dans
une autre loi sur un autre sujet
environnemental, mais on ne gère pas
la question climatique
comme préalable à tout débat
sur le système social,
sur la résistance
de notre système social,
sur l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat,
sur le logement,
sur la Sécurité sociale.
Et en fait, et quand je le pose
ou quand nous sommes
quelques-uns à le poser,
on nous prend
vraiment encore aujourd'hui en 2023
pour des hurluberlus.
Et ça, on a un sujet.
D'ailleurs, l'allocution
du président de la République
m'a fascinée. Il avait
des mesures très précises
sur l'économie, sur la santé, par
contre, sur l'écologie, c'était...
-Mais est-ce que vous voulez dire
qu'il faut tout faire partir
du climat ?
-Non, mais là, aujourd'hui...
-Il y a du social,
de l'économie...
-Aujourd'hui, le danger
est tel qu'on devrait s'interroger
sur l'effet de chaque mesure
que nous prenons
sur le réchauffement climatique
et la perte de biodiversité.
Toutes les décisions
que nous prenons
devraient être à l'aune de ça.
Quand on étudie un texte
sur les retraites, il y a
une étude d'impact adossée
à ce projet de loi.
On pourrait discuter de ce qu'elle
était, peu importe,
mais là, il y en avait une.
A la ligne
"impacts sur l'environnement",
il était noté "néant".
Néant.
Alors que travailler 2 ans de plus,
c'est produire
0,5 à 1 point de plus de PIB, donc
ça a un impact sur l'environnement.
Qu'on ne lie pas les choses
est aujourd'hui
à la source vraiment,
à mon avis, d'un très gros problème,
qui s'appelle le déni du caractère
systémique
face à laquelle nous sommes.
-Vous êtes d'accord
sur ce déni ? Jean de Kervasdoué ?
-Euh non, pas vraiment, parce que
je pense que personne ne nie
que la température...
Et ne nie, enfin pas, je pense, ici,
le rapport du GIEC.
Néanmoins, il est important
avant de commencer ce débat
de rappeler une chose assez simple,
c'est que l'écologie
dépend d'un écosystème.
Donc on a un écosystème planétaire
et donc les questions de climat
sont planétaires,
mais les autres questions
de l'écologie
dépendent d'un écosystème,
et notamment la question
de la biodiversité dépend
d'un écosystème spécifique
dans un endroit spécifique
sous un climat spécifique.
On ne peut pas en parler en général.
Donc je pense que c'est à tort
qu'on résume ou qu'on réduit
les problèmes de l'écologie
à la question
du climat.
Magali Reghezza-Zitt,
vous vous occupez
au ministère de la Recherche
de tous les sujets sciences humaines
et sciences sociales.
Est-ce que le climat impacte chacune
de vos disciplines ?
-Il y a plusieurs choses dans ce qui
a été dit et on mélange un peu tout.
Ce que montre le rapport du GIEC,
c'est-à-dire
ce que montre la science,
c'est qu'à un moment, il y a
des limites dures au développement
de tous les êtres humains
sur la planète.
Elles ont été posées.
C'est le niveau de réchauffement,
au-delà de 2 degrés, on entre
dans des incertitudes telles
que ça devient compliqué
et qu'on a de moins en moins
de capacités d'adaptation,
notamment pour les plus défavorisés,
pour les plus démunis,
y compris en France,
c'est pas juste
très loin de nous.
Une autre limite dure, c'est
l'effondrement de la biodiversité.
On sait qu'à 3 degrés, on est à 20 %
du vivant qui s'effondre.
Derrière,
ce sont des risques boomerang
pour la santé humaine,
l'agriculture. Sans biodiversité,
on ne peut pas cultiver,
manger, etc. C'est le cadrage.
Ensuite, derrière,
il y a cette idée de se dire
est-ce qu'on climatise tout
et je pense qu'il y a
un malentendu dans ce qu'a
expliqué madame Rousseau.
Ca peut être intéressant
de discuter là-dessus.
D'une certaine façon,
ces limites planétaires,
que sont le climat, la biodiversité,
etc., doivent devenir
des cadres méthodologiques.
C'est la nouvelle règle du jeu.
A chaque fois qu'on va sortir
de ces limites, en réalité, on va
mettre en place des politiques
qui, d'une façon ou d'une autre,
à moyen, court ou long terme vont
se retourner contre nous
et là arrive la politique.
Ce que dit le rapport GIEC
et ce que dit aussi le Haut Conseil
pour le Climat qui évalue
les trajectoires de la France,
c'est qu'il y a
des choses qui sont faites,
mais qu'on ne va pas
assez vite. Ce qui met
les scientifiques aujourd'hui
dans une situation de colère
et d'impuissance,
c'est que les solutions existent.
Elles sont évaluées à nouveau
sur la base de la science.
Elles sont faisables,
accessibles, finançables.
En revanche, ce qui manque,
c'est justement le politique.
C'est pas, une fois qu'on a dit...
Le politique au sens d'un débat,
d'un projet avec derrière
des valeurs qui sont différentes,
parce que le chemin pour atteindre
ces objectifs de décarbonation
va supposer des choix,
des priorités.
Et le problème qu'on va avoir,
et je reviens à la question posée,
c'est que les scientifiques
aujourd'hui sont sommés de
se substituer de par leur expertise
à des décisions
qui sont des décisions
qui devraient être prises
de manière démocratique, y compris,
là, je m'adresse au médecin...
-Les politiques entravent
la puissance
d'agir des scientifiques ?
-Non. Les scientifiques
ne sont pas là pour se substituer
au politique.
Le médecin ne dit pas
si c'est lui...
-Attendez...
-Si le malade doit se soigner.
-Sandrine Rousseau veut répondre.
-Oui. Pardon,
pour vous répondre sur le fond,
il y a les politiques écologiques,
on a des débats
sur la trajectoire énergétique, etc.
Mais aujourd'hui, on ne peut plus
prendre une politique publique,
la décision d'une politique publique
sans en regarder les effets
sur le climat et la biodiversité.
Aujourd'hui,
ça n'est absolument pas fait.
Et on considère
que ce sont des domaines étanches
les uns avec les autres,
alors qu'évidemment que non.
Et c'est en cela qu'on n'a pas
une vision à mon avis suffisante
de la gravité de la crise
qui arrive, parce que si on en avait
une clairvoyante sur l'ampleur
de cette crise, alors tout euro
public que l'on dépense
aurait une espèce d'étude d'impact
sur ses effets sur le climat,
sur sa préservation ou pas,
sur la biodiversité
et sur la quantité d'eau,
enfin sur l'ensemble des...
-Pardonnez-moi,
mais pour le téléspectateur,
c'est pas très clair. Qui entrave
d'en faire plus dans ce domaine ?
Jean de Kervasdoué.
-D'abord, nous ne sommes pas
les seuls sur la planète.
Donc commençons...
-On peut parler de la France
et de la planète.
-Oui, d'accord,
nous ne sommes pas les seuls
sur la planète
et l'évolution du climat
va dépendre de nombreux pays,
à commencer par l'Inde,
les Etats-Unis et d'autres pays.
Si on veut revenir à la France,
le problème est que les écologistes
politiques ont agi
contre l'écologie,
et notamment contre le réchauffement
climatique, en étant ennemis
depuis l'origine du nucléaire,
en étant...
en empêchant qu'on fabrique des OGM.
Si on s'intéresse
au réchauffement climatique
et à la biodiversité,
la meilleure manière
de sélectionner des plantes,
je me suis occupé
beaucoup d'hôpitaux dans ma vie,
mais j'ai fait aussi l'Agro et les
Eaux et Forêts, j'ai des notions...
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-Non, mais c'est quand même
important de rappeler
que les écologistes politiques
ont agi contre l'écologie
et qu'ils se sont...
-Je ne peux pas laisser dire ça.
-Voilà. Je prends deux exemples.
-En aucune manière.
-Vous avez soutenu les OGM ?
-Certainement pas.
Et encore heureux qu'on ne les a
pas soutenus. Mais les OGM,
c'est de la technologie
sur le vivant. C'est pas ça,
la préservation
de la biodiversité. La préservation
de la biodiversité,
c'est de préserver
la qualité des écosystèmes
pour qu'il y ait
une forme d'équilibre.
-Les êtres humains ont passé
10 000 ans depuis l'agriculture
à sélectionner des plantes...
-Mais pas à transformer leur ADN.
-Mais si. Bien sûr que si.
-Laissez-moi avoir d'autres avis.
Emmanuelle Galichet,
dans votre enseignement,
prenez-vous en considération
ce primat du climat ?
-Evidemment.
On le prend tous les jours.
Dans toutes les formations
en France, c'est devenu central,
notamment chez les ingénieurs,
puisqu'aucune formation d'ingénieurs
ne doit éviter
la question du climat,
mais cette question du climat,
elle est
trop vague, en disant juste
il faut parler du climat.
Tout est corrélé évidemment,
on est tous d'accord,
aussi bien les usages de l'eau,
l'énergie,
l'énergie est partout,
tout le monde en a besoin,
et elle permet aussi d'avoir
des usages de l'eau corrects,
l'agriculture a besoin
d'énergie et d'eau.
En fait, il faut avoir une
stratégie, une vision long terme.
C'est peut-être là-dessus finalement
qu'on est en train de discuter.
Les politiques doivent
prendre en compte
les expertises scientifiques.
Il y a aucun doute.
Surtout, ensuite, ils doivent
donner une stratégie,
une vision à long terme
de comment on arrive à un but.
Et aujourd'hui,
tout est un peu noyé,
parce que les politiques ont
un peu la tête dans les étoiles
en se disant, je sais pas,
qu'est-ce que je dois faire, etc.
La 1re chose,
c'est s'asseoir autour d'une table
et trouver une vision long terme
avec une stratégie, des étapes,
pour arriver
à cette neutralité carbone en 2050.
Si vous faites l'interview
de n'importe quel politique,
il est pas sûr
que vous trouviez quelqu'un
qui dise il faut faire ça
en 2020, ça en 2030. Donc
la stratégie n'est pas mis en place.
-Jean Jouzel. Je me mets
à la place du téléspectateur.
A écouter ce qui est dit,
il ne comprend pas
d'où vient la lenteur
à aller plus vite. Vous avez côtoyé
les grands de ce monde, est-ce que
c'est eux qui freinent ? Est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre science, politique,
industrie ? Qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on n'arrive pas
à avoir de meilleurs
chiffres dans ce domaine ?
-D'abord, on m'a invité
à parler du climat,
donc je l'ai fait tout à l'heure,
mais je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse dissocier
le problème du changement climatique
de l'ensemble du mode fonctionnement
de notre société.
C'est très important.
On ne peut pas dissocier
le climat, Emmanuelle l'a dit,
de la biodiversité,
du cycle de l'eau,
de la sécurité alimentaire.
On ne peut pas non plus le dissocier
de ses aspects sociétaux,
en termes de bassin d'emplois,
de ses aspects économiques
et même de ses aspects culturels.
Donc c'est quoi ? Quand on parle
de neutralité carbone,
je crois que...
Forcément, ça irriguera
le mode de fonctionnement,
le développement de nos sociétés,
au cours des prochaines décennies.
C'est bien tout cela.
Je me suis intéressé
à la transition écologique,
en particulier au titre
d'un rapport sur l'enseignement
de la transition
dans l'enseignement supérieur.
Eh bien, c'est clair
que c'est cette vision globale
de notre société
de cette transition
qu'il faut prendre.
Alors, pourquoi
ne va-t-on pas
assez vite pour le climat ?
Il y a quand même...
Alors, d'un côté,
je suis en phase,
voilà, je suis en phase
avec les objectifs de la France tels
qu'ils sont inscrits dans la loi.
Je m'y suis intéressé,
l'objectif de division par 6,
neutralité carbone en 2050,
ça me va très bien.
Le problème, il n'est pas
dans les objectifs affichés.
Il est dans la façon
dont on ne le respecte pas.
Quand on regarde,
on y reviendra peut-être,
on est à 20 %
d'énergies renouvelables,
on doit en être à 24 %.
Comment va-t-on aller
vers 32 ou plus ?
On y reviendra, mais...
Je crois qu'il y a
une stratégie nationale
bas carbone où toutes les étapes
sont bien inscrites.
-Il y a 18 mois,
vous disiez la même chose,
ce qui montre une continuité
dans votre pensée.
-Tout à fait. Oui !
Merci.
-Mais ça veut dire quoi ?
Ca veut dire
qu'on affiche des objectifs
et on triche sur leur réalisation ?
-Oui, je le crains. En tout cas,
je crois que c'est le diagnostic,
Magali nous le redira,
du Haut Conseil pour le Climat.
On ne va pas assez vite
et même notre président a dit
qu'il fallait doubler le rythme
de diminution de nos émissions
d'ici 2030. Comment fait-on ?
C'est reconnu sur la place publique.
Nous n'allons pas assez vite
par rapport aux objectifs affichés.
-Je voudrais prendre les problèmes
les uns après les autres.
Magali Reghezza-Zitt,
je voudrais vous interroger
sur l'eau, actualité violente
avec la fameuse bassine
de Sainte-Soline.
L'agriculture française
a-t-elle besoin de ces réservoirs
d'eau ?
Et d'une manière générale,
y a-t-il un risque
de pénurie d'eau ?
-Déjà, on confond tout.
Parce que la sécheresse,
c'est pas forcément la pénurie.
La sécheresse dans le désert,
il y a pas de risque.
Le problème de la pénurie,
c'est un déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande.
Dans un climat qui change
et on le voit déjà
depuis la décennie 90-2018,
en gros à partir de 2002,
ce qu'on appelle
l'eau renouvelable en France,
qui n'est pas évapotranspirée,
l'eau qui est à disposition,
a baissé globalement sur la France
d'à peu près
15 %, 15 à 14 %.
-Vous parlez
d'eau potable ?
-D'eau renouvelable.
L'eau qu'on peut utiliser sur un
territoire pour faire très simple.
L'offre baisse. De l'autre côté,
notre demande sociale est très haute
et elle ne cesse d'augmenter.
Et dans un climat qui change
avec des étés plus chauds
et plus secs, il va falloir,
notamment à certains moments,
on va avoir besoin d'eau
pour irriguer par exemple, parce que
vos végétaux, il faut les irriguer.
On va peut-être avoir besoin d'eau
pour refroidir la ville.
On va avoir des besoins d'eau
qui peuvent augmenter dans le temps.
Donc les demandes augmentent
et l'offre baisse. A partir de là,
ce que dit la science, c'est simple.
Un, il faut faire
ces réserves d'eau pour les moments
vraiment critiques. Mais deux,
si on ne regarde
que cette stabilisation
de l'offre, alors que notre offre
baisse structurellement,
ça marche pas.
L'idée est de trouver localement
les solutions qui répondront
à ces besoins d'eau
pour éviter justement
les pénuries, en essayant, un,
d'être le plus efficaces possible
dans notre consommation,
et deux, de faire
ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
sobriété, c'est-à-dire d'éviter
les usages qu'on juge
non essentiels. Pour ça,
on a une boîte à outils énorme.
Je prends l'agriculture. On peut
agir sur les variétés,
sur les espèces, on peut agir aussi
sur la manière
de produire, de cultiver.
Mais on va devoir aussi agir
sur nos consommations, donc agir
sur les chaînes de valeur,
sur les chaînes productives.
Après, il va falloir
se poser la question.
On a construit ces bassines,
qui vont chercher l'eau
dans les nappes. C'est ça qui pose
problème. Celles qui sont
construites, elles sont construites.
Est-ce une solution d'avenir
de construire partout
et sur tout le territoire
ces infrastructures énergivores,
où l'eau peut s'évaporer ?
Ca va dépendre.
A chaque fois qu'on fait
ce type d'infrastructure,
on devrait se poser la question,
est-ce qu'on n'a pas
une solution plus efficace
et meilleure ? Sinon c'est
la maladaptation. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ? Ce sont des solutions
soit qui verrouillent nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
soit qui empêchent
des transformations plus profondes,
qui nous mettront à l'abri
dans un climat qui va continuer
à changer tant qu'on n'aura pas
atteint la neutralité carbone
de cette disponibilité en eau
qui va baisser
de manière chronique.
-Jean de Kervasdoué.
-Je suis d'accord
avec ce que vous dites,
mais pas du tout
avec le ton que vous donnez,
parce que vous inquiétez à mon avis
inutilement à ce stade.
Alors, à ma connaissance, parce que
j'ai écrit un livre sur l'eau,
donc j'ai quelques vagues notions
sur ce sujet,
j'ai construit
des barrages, etc. Donc,
à ma connaissance,
quand il pleut en France,
64 % de l'eau s'évapore
tout de suite,
34 % s'infiltrent
et nous rejetterions
176 milliards de mètres cubes
s'il n'y avait
aucune activité humaine en France.
De fait,
nous en rejetons 171 milliards.
-Nous la rejetons où ?
-Nous en rejetons de fait...
Dans les fleuves,
dans la mer.
La différence,
notamment l'irrigation
en France, ce n'est
que 3 milliards de mètres cubes
et ce chiffre baisse,
plutôt il n'augmente pas.
Les centrales techniques
et les centrales nucléaires,
c'est 1 milliard
et le reste, c'est 1 milliard.
Donc vous inquiétez
de manière inutile
nos téléspectateurs, en laissant
croire qu'on n'a aucune marge,
en laissant croire qu'il n'y a pas
d'eau dans les nappes phréatiques.
Or il y a des réserves colossales.
-C'est faux.
-J'ai regardé
les statistiques encore hier.
-Excusez-moi,
mais ce que vous dites,
c'est faux.
Je suis désolée de le dire.
-Ce que vous dites est inquiétant.
-Mais...
-Ecoutez...
-Vous parlez d'abord d'un climat,
je sais pas quand vous avez fait
vos études, mais ce climat
n'existe plus. Deuxièmement,
vous reprenez
un argument climatosceptique
selon lequel l'eau qui va
dans les fleuves est perdue.
Et vous prenez un problème d'échelle
qui est un problème très compliqué.
En fonction du niveau national, du
type de territoire et de l'échelle,
les moyennes ne valent rien.
-Vous avez le droit
d'être en désaccord.
-Vous faites les questions
et les réponses,
ça me paraît compliqué.
Quand vous regardez
les statistiques...
Le problème,
il est assez simple à dire,
quel est l'impact météo
et quel est l'impact climatique ?
Bon. Quand vous regardez
les statistiques météorologiques,
en France, l'année la plus sèche
du 20e siècle, c'est 1920.
Attendez, c'est la vérité.
Ecoutez, c'est la vérité.
Voilà. Et il y a eu
quasiment 14 mois sans pluie.
Quand on regarde la distribution,
c'est-à-dire la moyenne
et l'écart type,
on est encore
dans les variations météorologiques.
Je lis les rapports du GIEC.
Je pense qu'il y a une évolution
des extrêmes et qu'on est en train
de changer
et la moyenne et l'écart type,
mais pour l'instant...
Et en plus, un certain nombre
de modèles de prévision climatique
prévoient qu'on aurait plutôt
un excédent d'eau
dans les zones tempérées.
-Sandrine Rousseau.
-Non, mais surtout...
Enfin, là, on est
typiquement
dans ce à quoi on se confronte.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a des gens
qui viennent nous expliquer,
qui sont pas chercheurs,
qui sont pas politiques,
et qui viennent nous dire,
on a 34 %, on a X %,
avec un ton très docte
et qui nous disent
il y a rien à faire. C'est ça,
le climatoscepticisme
aujourd'hui. Et c'est
un vrai sujet de comment
on le contre, parce que derrière,
il y a des intérêts économiques,
des rapports de domination,
pardon de le dire,
mais ça me semble assez flagrant,
et donc comment on change
notre structure sociale ?
Si on s'intéresse à l'eau, certes,
on peut discourir des bassines,
mais la question profonde,
c'est à quoi sert cette eau ?
Pourquoi on en a
besoin ? L'usage
de ces bassines en l'occurrence,
c'est l'agriculture.
Est-ce que l'on peut
conserver le modèle agricole
tel qu'il est
actuellement dans un système
météorologique et climatique
qui se modifie ?
-Il y a de moins en moins
d'agriculteurs.
-Oui, mais qui ont besoin de plus
en plus d'eau. La question, c'est
comment on fait en sorte
de diminuer la quantité d'eau.
Pour cela, la culture
la plus contestée est celle du maïs,
dont on sait
qu'elle nécessite beaucoup d'eau,
mais c'est aussi
l'élevage par exemple.
Et donc il y a besoin de revoir...
C'est en cela
que je vous disais qu'il y avait
une vision systémique à avoir.
Et je prends
ma casquette de politique.
Quand on a une loi
sur l'alimentation,
on doit aussi interroger
les décisions prises
sur l'alimentation
en regard de la consommation
d'eau nécessaire
et en regard de l'évolution
du système climatique
et de biodiversité.
Et là, on n'y est pas. Par exemple,
on a eu un débat sur la quantité
de viande dans les cantines,
où il était manifeste
qu'il n'y avait pas de
volonté de modifier
cette consommation de viande
et pourtant, ça fait partie
des gestes qui ont un impact
sur la quantité d'eau
dont nous avons besoin
en agriculture et en élevage.
-Ca dépend des élevages.
-On a compris votre position.
C'est assez clair.
-Ecoutez, on ne peut pas laisser
un débat trop technique.
Vous voulez vous en mêler,
Jean Jouzel.
N'y a-t-il pas assez d'eau ?
-Non, mais, même dans les régions
où les précipitations
restent inconstantes,
le réchauffement climatique
augmente l'évaporation.
C'est très clair.
Donc il y a un déficit
et je suis
complètement en phase avec Magali.
Il y a un déficit de 15 %
par rapport à l'eau disponible.
Ensuite, du point de vue
de l'hydrologue, je ne sais pas,
mais la meilleure façon
de garder l'eau considérée comme
un bien commun, c'est de la laisser
rentrer dans les sols. On peut voir
le point de vue de l'agriculture,
c'est autre chose, mais il faut bien
se placer. Conserve-t-on
l'eau pour une utilisation optimale
pour l'ensemble des usages
ou privilégie-t-on
un usage ? C'est un choix possible,
qui est un choix de société.
Mais il faut bien comprendre que,
du point de vue du cycle de l'eau,
la meilleure façon
de la conserver est
de la laisser rentrer.
-On parle d'une solution miracle
avec le recyclage
des eaux usées.
On cite certains pays.
Est-ce vraiment...
-En France, c'est 1 %.
Je suis intervenu. Ou à peu près, de
l'ordre de 1 %, c'est pas beaucoup.
Donc oui, c'est bien de le faire.
Je le pense. On est très en retard
par rapport à d'autres pays,
mais c'est pas ça
qui va nous sauver
par rapport aux 15 % cités
par Magali Reghezza-Zitt.
-Bon, écoutez,
on ne mettra pas
tout le monde d'accord
sur la question de l'eau.
On va avancer.
Néanmoins des milliards d'individus
n'ont pas accès
ni à l'eau potable
ni à une alimentation saine,
ne disposent pas
de l'électricité,
il manque de sources d'énergie
et on s'aperçoit que,
pour certaines populations,
il y a un cumul de ces difficultés.
Que peut-on dire de ça,
Emmanuelle Galichet ?
-C'est évident
que, si on regarde la situation
planétaire aujourd'hui,
elle est dramatique
et elle l'est pas chez nous,
mais dans les pays sous-développés
sans accès à l'électricité.
Un homme sur...
Un être humain sur neuf n'a pas
d'électricité encore aujourd'hui.
Donc, en fait, on a aussi nous,
en tant que nation industrialisée
et de haute technologie,
des responsabilités
envers ces peuples.
-C'est pas la faute
du réchauffement climatique.
du réchauffement climatique,
c'est la faute
de pays industrialisés
qui ont peut-être pensé
qu'à leur exploitation et qui,
aujourd'hui, doivent...
Nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre diminuent,
dans les pays industrialisés, les
pays en développement augmentent.
C'est normal. Ils essaient aussi
de sortir de la pauvreté.
Donc l'électricité est aussi
un bien commun et doit être
un bien commun mondial
autant que l'eau. Et ils sont
absolument corrélés.
On parlait des eaux usées,
pour devenir une eau potable, c'est
absolument énergivore.
Le dessalement de l'eau de mer aussi
est une technique qui est utilisée
en Israël, dans beaucoup de pays,
en Espagne,
et qui est absolument énergivore.
Donc vous voyez qu'à chaque fois,
c'est bien ça où il y a
une vision stratégique à avoir.
Je suis d'accord
avec madame Rousseau,
il faut, à chaque fois
qu'on prend une décision,
regarder ce que ça va
impacter autour de nous.
Et l'énergie, l'eau, l'agriculture,
tout est corrélé finalement.
Donc il y a intérêt aujourd'hui
à ce que les pays industrialisés
donnent l'exemple déjà
avec des énergies décarbonées,
mettent la priorité
sur les énergies décarbonées,
et puissent donner
des solutions technologiques
aux pays qui n'en ont pas
les moyens, en fait.
-Madame Rousseau, que dites-vous
de ce dialogue nord-sud
avec la pénitence d'un côté
et le gaspillage de l'autre ?
-Il est indispensable...
Ca va être le grand sujet
des années à venir.
Est-ce que l'on continue
à s'accaparer des ressources
et des technologies
et à en faire profit,
et du coup, à laisser
une partie du monde à l'écart
de la transformation écologique
indispensable
aussi dans ces pays-là ? Ou est-ce
que l'on est dans un partage,
dans une coopération
et dans une reconnaissance
de notre responsabilité,
qu'elle soit historique
ou à l'heure où nous parlons ?
Et en fait, aujourd'hui,
c'est un peu, à mon sens, l'impensé
des discussions. D'ailleurs,
les pays moins riches essaient
de les mettre sur la table
des négociations dans toutes les COP
avec des fonds de compensation,
mais à la fin,
les pays riches rechignent
à reconnaître
leur responsabilité et historique
et dans le moment de...
-Oui, mais c'est pas...
C'est pas des pays riches
comme la France qui polluent.
Le premier pollueur est la Chine,
le deuxième,
les Etats-Unis, le 3e, l'Inde.
-C'est pas vrai
historiquement.
-C'est pas vrai.
On émet en France autant
qu'un Chinois en moyenne d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
par tête d'habitant.
-Oui, du coup, ça nous exonère pas
d'une responsabilité, en fait.
-On est d'accord.
-Passons
à un sujet peut-être qui fâche, mais
peut-être que vous serez d'accord.
En matière d'énergie décarbonée,
si on prend
le mix énergétique français,
il est fait de nucléaire
et d'énergies renouvelables.
On n'est pas comme les Allemands...
Attendez, attendez...
Essentiellement.
Il y a du reste aussi,
mais en tout cas, on n'a pas
autant de charbon et de lignite
que les Allemands.
Est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour considérer
que, pour la France,
il n'y a pas d'autre solution
qu'avoir
un mix énergétique
avec du nucléaire,
des énergies renouvelables,
de l'hydraulique également
et un peu du reste ?
-Mais évidemment non.
Ce sera sans surprise.
-Dans la situation actuelle,
vous feriez quoi, madame Rousseau ?
-Il y a toujours ce non-dit,
dans tous les débats énergétiques,
qui est la question
de la sobriété, c'est-à-dire
comment on diminue massivement
nos besoins énergétiques.
En l'occurrence, le nucléaire,
présenté comme une espèce
de technologie presque magique
qui résoudrait nos problèmes,
comme les bassines ou les OGM,
pour moi, c'est vraiment
de l'ordre de la pensée magique.
Parce qu'on construirait
quelques centrales, alors,
on se sortirait
de la question énergétique.
Evidemment pas. Par ailleurs,
les centrales nucléaires
ont besoin d'eau et on voit bien
que les sécheresses font
qu'on va manquer d'eau.
Est-ce qu'il y a besoin
d'utiliser de l'eau
pour refroidir des centrales ?
-Celles qui sont au bord de la mer.
-Oui, mais celles qui sont au bord
de la mer sont en zone submersible.
C'est le cas de Gravelines qui est
une des principales d'Europe.
-Non.
-Si, elle est construite
sur un polder.
Si, je suis désolée.
La région de Dunkerque
est un polder.
-Sur ce point-là,
Emmanuelle Galichet ?
-Toute l'adaptation
des centrales nucléaires
et de l'industrie nucléaire est
en marche. Notamment à Gravelines,
il y a une digue.
Les gens, là où ils habitent,
disent que si par hasard
il y a un problème d'inondation,
tout le monde se réfugiera
dans la centrale, le seul
endroit qui ne sera pas inondé.
Donc sur ce point-là...
-Mais non.
On aura d'autres problèmes donc...
S'il y a une inondation dans le
nord, vous aurez d'autres problèmes.
-Profitez-en pour dire ce que vous
pensez. Y a-t-il un autre choix ?
-Il faut faire une très grande
différence entre un mix énergétique
et un mix électrique.
-Oui, on est bien d'accord.
Il y a plus de nucléaire
dans l'électricité
que dans l'énergie,
il y a 70 % et 25 %.
-Le combat
absolument fondamental aujourd'hui
des pays industrialisés
et même des autres,
c'est de sortir des fossiles.
Quoi qu'on fasse, c'est les énergies
fossiles qui nous embêtent,
qui sont la base de tous nos
problèmes. Donc quel que soit...
Chaque pays a le droit de faire le
mix qu'il veut. Nous, il se trouve
qu'on a un mix électrique
largement nucléaire
du fait de notre histoire
et donc, je dirais,
nous avons une petite avance
par rapport à certains autres pays,
du fait qu'on a
92 % de notre électricité
qui est décarbonée.
Ca veut pas dire
qu'il faut s'arrêter là
et dire, on a tout fini.
Ca veut dire
qu'il faut aller voir
là où il y a du charbon, du pétrole
et du gaz et de le remplacer
par des énergies renouvelables
et des énergies décarbonées.
C'est ça, notre combat,
rien d'autre.
-Madame Rousseau.
-C'est 80-20.
-On est à 70 et 25, je crois.
Madame Rousseau,
si vous arrivez au pouvoir
dans 4 ou 5 ans
et qu'on a relancé le nucléaire,
avec 6 EPR 2
plus 6 autres qui suivront,
est-ce que vous démantelez ?
Parce que,
dans la situation française
et que l'électricité...
-Je rappelle
que l'EPR actuellement
en construction est
toujours pas en activité,
qu'il a connu retard sur retard,
qu'il a des fissures.
Aujourd'hui, on n'a pas d'EPR
qui fonctionne correctement.
Donc miser sur une technologie...
Par ailleurs,
je reviens sur Gravelines...
-Taishan aussi.
-Non, mais celui de Finlande...
Je comprends même pas
pourquoi vous vous revendiquez
scientifique et que vous ne regardez
pas la réalité sur le nucléaire.
Ils parlent tous en même temps.
-On ne la regarde pas comme vous.
-La centrale de Gravelines
est entourée d'une digue,
elle est sur un polder, c'est-à-dire
que le jour où la mer monte,
il va y avoir
tout un triangle entre Dunkerque
presque jusqu'à Armentières
sous l'eau
et on aura notre centrale
certes avec une digue, on parle pas
des événements climatiques extrêmes,
et au plein milieu de la mer.
Pourquoi ne pas vouloir développer
davantage des énergies renouvelables
type éolien,
type solaire, par exemple.
On a eu tout un débat
à l'Assemblée nationale
sur le fait qu'une majorité
dans l'Assemblée ne voulait pas
mettre des panneaux solaires sur
les toits déjà existants. Pourquoi ?
Qu'est-ce que ça gêne
de mettre des panneaux
sur les toits déjà existants ?
Pourquoi ne faisons-nous pas
cet effort de technologies,
qui sont finalement légères,
plutôt que d'aller vers des EPR
dont l'avenir est encore incertain,
désolée
de le présenter comme ça.
-Sincèrement,
madame Rousseau, aujourd'hui,
le modèle français fait que
l'électricité pour 70 % est produite
à partir du nucléaire.
-Oui.
-Pensez-vous sincèrement
qu'on peut inverser
cette chose-là ou ramener à 50 % ?
-Oui, je le pense.
Bien sûr que je le pense.
-Vous le pensez.
Et vous, Jean Jouzel ?
-J'aime bien m'appuyer
sur le rapport du Réseau
de Transport d'Electricité.
Une 1re conclusion importante,
c'est que la France n'atteindra pas
la neutralité carbone
sans un développement
significatif du renouvelable.
C'est la conclusion
la plus importante pour moi.
La 2e, effectivement,
ce serait plus facile, c'est
les points 4 et 5 du rapport RTE,
si on construisait
de nouvelles centrales nucléaires.
Mais il faut bien partir du fait
que ce qui est important aussi,
c'est le développement
du renouvelable.
Je ne suis pas antinucléaire,
mais on n'arrivera pas
à atteindre la neutralité carbone
même avec les 14 EPR
sans un développement massif
du renouvelable
qui ralentit actuellement.
Par exemple, c'est très clair,
on a beaucoup de retard
sur l'éolien en mer,
on parle de projets,
mais ils prendront du temps.
Il faut le mettre en avant.
Donc évidemment je pense
que l'important,
l'électricité, c'est 25 %
ou 30 % de notre énergie,
c'est comment on fait
pour remplacer les 70 %.
Il faut de la sobriété.
Sandrine Rousseau l'a
redit, mais je crois
qu'il faut effectivement
développer ce mix énergétique
de façon intelligente, mais pas
en abandonnant le renouvelable,
son développement massif,
je le redis,
au bénéfice du nucléaire.
Il faut, je crois,
développer les deux, en tout cas,
mais c'est pas ce qu'on est en train
de faire. C'est ma crainte.
Je redis, on devrait être à 24 %
de renouvelable, on est à 20 %.
Si on avait été à 24 %,
nous aurions moins de problèmes
face au problème énergétique
posé par l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie.
-Emmanuelle Galichet.
-Vous avez raison,
il faut diversifier les mix.
Ca, c'est
une des conditions sine qua non.
Après, les ENR aujourd'hui,
on se trouve
devant une problématique d'opinion
publique assez importante
et qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à le
développer. Il faut aller au-delà.
Il faut faire de la pédagogie
auprès des populations
pour qu'on puisse développer
très fortement notamment
l'éolien offshore, qui ait un bon
coefficient de disponibilité, qui
permet de faire de l'électricité.
Je voudrais rebondir
sur RTE
et sur ces scénarios pour 2050.
En fait, ils développent
6 scénarios.
Ils diminuent.
On doit faire moins 40 % quand même
de consommation énergétique,
donc la sobriété,
l'efficacité énergétique et ensuite,
il y a l'électrification des usages.
Et ça, c'est fondamental.
Si on veut décarboner notamment
notre industrie, qui est
extrêmement carbonée aujourd'hui,
il faut qu'on électrifie.
On va passer de 35 %...
Le minimum, c'est 35 %,
voire 60 % de plus
d'électricité à l'horizon 2050.
Ca veut dire que les ENR
ont toute leur place.
L'hydroélectricité,
on va faire attention,
parce que la sécheresse, si on a
des pertes d'eau, nos lacs,
nos barrages sont beaucoup plus bas
et on a des problèmes
sur l'électricité hydroélectrique
et le nucléaire en fait partie.
Ce sont 3 solutions
absolument incontournables.
-Merci.
Vous venez de voir cette citation
de Simenon, un auteur de romans
policiers peut-être pour vous
mettre d'accord. "L'homme a voulu
vivre en société, mais aussi
"depuis qu'elle existe,
"l'homme emploie
une bonne part de son énergie
"à lutter contre elle." Alors,
l'eau, l'énergie, la sécurité
alimentaire,
en partie liées par l'économie,
l'écologie, la solidarité. Quel lien
de parenté
établissez-vous entre eux,
notamment dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique ?
-Je voudrais revenir à ce qu'a dit
Jean Jouzel tout à l'heure.
-On va essayer d'avancer un peu
si vous voulez.
-Mais une nuance de pensée,
René Dubos disait "penser
globalement, agir localement",
je pense qu'on peut
avoir en permanence en tête
le réchauffement climatique, mais
on est obligé d'agir localement.
Et donc les actions en France
ou même en ce qui concerne l'eau
en Bretagne ou en amont de Toulouse
ou sur le couloir rhodanien
ne sont pas les mêmes,
comme ne sont pas les mêmes
les politiques agricoles.
Donc je pense qu'effectivement,
on s'oriente vers des moments
très, très difficiles.
Je partage avec vous
et avec beaucoup d'entre nous
ce que vous avez dit sur les
problèmes nord-sud. Je pense que
les 100... milliards, je crois, oui,
les 100 milliards ou 100 millions,
bref, ne sont pas suffisants
et qu'on voit bien
et on va voir encore cette année
se développer des famines...
-Oui, mais venons
sur la liaison que je vous propose.
Pensez-vous que tout ça est lié
et le réchauffement climatique
les relie
encore plus ?
-Par essence,
je pense que, malheureusement,
il ne faut pas trop globaliser,
parce qu'on ne sait plus
comment agir.
On est obligé
d'avoir des hiérarchies.
Si on considère que le réchauffement
climatique est l'objectif central
de l'avenir de l'humanité,
ensuite on décline
avec d'autres objectifs,
qui sont la survie des gens,
leur santé, l'alimentation,
etc., etc.
Mais malheureusement
ce qui mène le monde aujourd'hui,
c'est quand même
beaucoup plus l'économie
et, à mon avis, ça va continuer
à l'être, c'est beaucoup plus
l'indépendance des pays,
c'est beaucoup plus les guerres
déclarées ou latentes. Donc
je ne suis pas d'un optimisme fou.
-Magali Reghezza-Zitt,
là-dessus, sur cette liaison ?
-Elle est posée désormais
dans le rapport
du GIEC, qui démontre que, dans
un monde trop réchauffé par l'homme,
où la biodiversité s'effondre,
l'atteinte des objectifs
de développement durable,
c'est-à-dire du bien-être humain,
au niveau mondial ou local,
pour tous est impossible.
A l'inverse, et c'est le paradoxe,
il existe des formes de transition,
donc des choix et des arbitrages
qui font qu'on peut atteindre
ces objectifs climatiques
avec des cobénéfices. Le rapport
de synthèse du GIEC démontre
action par action,
secteur par secteur,
tous les cobénéfices
en termes de santé, d'alimentation.
Donc l'idée derrière,
c'est de se dire
que, face à un climat qui change,
les plus vulnérables,
sont ceux qui cumulent
le plus d'inégalités. C'est un fait
scientifiquement démontré.
-Le climat
aggrave la situation ?
-Oui. Et ce qui est extrêmement
injuste,
et là, on en arrive au sentiment
et donc à la réponse
politique, c'est que
les coûts de transition
portent pour l'instant
sur les plus démunis. C'est
la double peine. Quand on va
mettre des mesures pour essayer
de réorienter, ce sont les plus
démunis qui sont les plus fragiles.
On le voit chez les agriculteurs,
d'où l'idée dans le rapport
du Haut Conseil pour le Climat
de mesures structurelles. Le jour
où les agriculteurs en fabriquant
selon des principes
plus écologiquement vertueux,
énergétiquement,
de sobriété en sol et en eau,
ça sera rémunérateur
par rapport à faire autrement.
-Mais je voudrais
vous poser une question
que le téléspectateur
se pose. Si on prend la France
d'aujourd'hui,
qu'il s'agisse de l'énergie,
qu'il s'agisse de l'alimentation
et d'autres sujets,
on est en baisse par rapport
aux décennies précédentes.
Il y a 20 ans, on disait
que notre système énergétique était
flamboyant. Sur le plan
agroalimentaire, on est dépassé
par une nation comme l'Allemagne.
Les Pays-Bas également. Comment
vous expliquez cette chose-là ?
-Ca dépend ce qu'on appelle...
Là aussi, on est dans un discours
qui est double et qui est pas
celui des scientifiques.
Il y a le plus et il y a le mieux.
-L'économie compte.
-Justement,
vous avez dit,
nous avons un système agricole,
depuis 1980, nous avions
2 millions d'agriculteurs en 1980.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à 400 000 agriculteurs.
Donc la question, c'est est-ce que
ces agriculteurs aujourd'hui,
on a moins, ils vivent mieux
avec plus de confort.
-C'est pas ce qu'ils disent.
-Donc il y a un problème. Ensuite,
ce que peut faire le scientifique,
c'est dire quoi ? C'est
si on fait ça, si on fait ça,
si on fait ça, on va dans le mur.
On sait scientifiquement
que telle solution n'est pas tenable
dans un climat qui change.
Ensuite, il y a des priorisations.
Et c'est bien là
tout l'enjeu de la politisation.
Ce que vous dites est très juste.
On est dans des sujets
qui ne sont finalement pas,
je ne le dis pas contre des
hommes politiques en particulier,
qui ne sont pas inscrits à l'agenda.
On discute d'économie, d'école...
La France a 67 millions
de spécialistes de la pédagogie,
on est tous enseignants,
tout le monde sait comment éduquer,
mais alors, par contre,
sur le climat, c'est trop compliqué.
Les plateaux télé sont remplis
de gens sur l'Ukraine,
mais quand il s'agit de climat,
c'est compliqué, "le téléspectateur
s'en rend pas compte".
Excusez-nous, mais ça fait partie de
la même donne que le vieillissement
de la population...
-Je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment politique,
Sandrine Rousseau.
Que pensez-vous
d'un certain déclassement
de la France, je pèse mes mots,
sur la production
agricole, sur l'énergie,
où on était quand même
en meilleure santé
il y a 2 ou 3 décennies ?
En termes économiques, et je sais
que l'économie vous parle.
-Oui,
puisque je suis
enseignante-chercheuse en économie,
avant d'avoir un mandat.
Mais poser la question
en ces termes, c'est poser
la question dans les termes
du monde d'avant.
On fait toujours plus, plus, plus.
C'est Kenneth Boulding,
on n'est pas sûr
que ce soit lui qui l'ai dit,
mais qui dit : "Pour croire
qu'une croissance infinie
"dans un monde fini est possible,
"il faut être
soit fou soit économiste."
-Mais vous vous apprêtez
à gouverner,
il y a le réel qui est là.
-Le réel, ce n'est pas de faire...
d'être dans une forme
de classement par rapport
aux Pays-Bas ou à l'Allemagne.
Le réel, c'est de se dire
comment on assure
l'autonomie alimentaire
de la France ? Et comment
on le fait
avec des méthodes agricoles
qui permettent
et de préserver l'eau
et de préserver les vers de terre,
parce que la quantité
de vers de terre dans nos sols
s'est absolument effondrée...
-Il faut autoriser le glyphosate.
-Non, on ne va pas
autoriser le glyphosate.
-Pour avoir des vers de terre, si.
-Et justement,
cette manière de poser la question,
de dire, on est en train de perdre
du champ vis-à-vis de machin...
-C'est une réalité
économique.
-Mais non.
-Comment, non ?
-Ca n'est pas le sujet principal,
mais comment on construit
une France résiliente
face au réchauffement climatique
et à la perte de biodiversité.
Et ça, pour cela,
il faut pas poser la question
de savoir si on est
en rang 1, en rang 2 ou en rang 3.
Il faut se dire, de quoi on a besoin
en termes d'alimentation
et comment on s'assure qu'on l'a.
-On a eu 2 ans de Covid,
il y a la guerre d'Ukraine,
on a vu les difficultés
sur le plan énergétique,
auparavant, avec beaucoup
de biens qui manquaient,
donc il faut se préoccuper
de l'industrialisation de la France.
-Sur la guerre d'Ukraine,
c'est un peu connexe,
mais un des sujets a été
qu'on n'a pas été capables
de se priver de gaz russe
en un temps très court, de sorte
qu'on n'a pas réussi
à mettre la pression sur la Russie
de manière suffisante
et qu'on est dans la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes.
-Ca veut dire quoi ?
-En coupant les vannes du gaz
et en n'en achetant plus.
Il y a vraiment quelque chose
de l'ordre d'un modèle
de résilience à penser
et on n'est pas là-dedans,
on est dans un modèle de croissance.
-On va conclure
et je voudrais conclure
en vous posant une question
politique, j'allais dire,
à chacun de vous, parce que,
dans les différends
entre la France et l'Allemagne,
on parle d'autonomie stratégique,
de souveraineté
stratégique et si on applique
cette souveraineté stratégique
à l'énergie, à l'alimentation,
le président de la République
parle, a dit,
on va reconquérir notre souveraineté
stratégique sur le plan
alimentaire, énergétique.
Alors, brièvement, chacun,
quelques secondes, vous y croyez,
Jean Jouzel ? Et à quelle échelle
de temps ? Et est-ce qu'on a
les investissements nécessaires
pour les technologies idoines
et permettre cette souveraineté
alimentaire, énergétique ?
-Souveraineté énergétique,
on en a parlé.
Je crois que la souveraineté
alimentaire, on la garde quand même,
on peut la garder avec le système
français. Il faut aussi
dans les deux cas, aussi bien
en termes de gaspillage alimentaire
que de sobriété énergétique, le mot
sobriété est aussi un peu essentiel.
C'est cela mon sentiment.
Donc il faut peut-être
que nous fassions
collectivement plus attention
à notre comportement
par rapport à l'alimentation,
à l'utilisation de l'énergie.
Maintenant,
je pense qu'il faut absolument que,
je le redis, la loi est là,
mais il faudrait que nous prenions
de véritables mesures pour tenir les
engagements. Je crois franchement
que diviser par 2 nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
par rapport à 90 en 2030,
c'est maintenant
et il faut aller 2 fois plus vite
et agir aujourd'hui.
C'est ça, le message,
pas dans 20 ans,
dans 30 ans, c'est important,
les investissements à long terme,
mais c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
d'ici 2030 pour tenir
les engagements qui sont de diviser
par 2 nos émissions. Bien sûr,
la souveraineté alimentaire
est importante également.
Je fais souvent des conférences
dans le monde agricole,
il y a un besoin d'adaptation
de l'agriculture
aux conditions du réchauffement
climatique, à l'accès à l'eau.
-Emmanuelle Galichet.
-La transition énergétique,
elle est absolument incontournable
évidemment,
mais elle va demander aussi
une transition sur les...
Elle va avoir
des problématiques géopolitiques
sur les matières premières.
On en a peu parlé.
Ca va être dramatique
si, encore une fois,
la France, on n'a pas une stratégie
pour être à des endroits clés
incontournables.
La Chine l'a compris, elle a
toutes les matières premières,
tous les processus
de transformation de l'industrie.
-On vous a compris,
pas de souveraineté sans...
-Sans une stratégie
sur les matières premières.
-Magali
Reghezza-Zitt, sur ce point
et pour conclure.
-Tout à fait d'accord,
cette transition est justement
une des clés de la souveraineté.
Si nous la ratons,
nous perdrons et de la crédibilité
et cette capacité à encore décider
pour l'alimentation,
pour l'eau,
pour toutes les ressources
dont on aura besoin.
-Jean de Kervasdoué.
-Oui, je suis d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit si ce n'est
que, quand on regarde la balance
des paiements agricoles,
on se rend compte
qu'elle serait déficitaire
s'il n'y avait pas le vin,
l'alcool et voilà.
On a une baisse
de la production agricole
qui se traduit
par une importation en France
du fait d'un certain nombre
de règlements discutables.
Et c'est ma critique de l'écologie
politique et non pas de l'écologie.
L'écologie politique a agi
contre l'écologie, elle a agi
contre l'écologie en se battant
contre le nucléaire.
Elle a agi contre l'agriculture
en interdisant les OGM.
Si on s'intéresse aux vers de terre,
il faut autoriser
le glyphosate, parce que ça permet
de faire des cultures sans sol. Etc.
On peut continuer.
-Merci. On vous a écouté.
Sandrine Rousseau,
vous, vous êtes
pour une souveraineté alimentaire,
souveraineté énergétique ?
Vous y croyez ?
-Et aussi pour vous mettre
dans un musée, il y a quelque chose
de l'ordre de la pureté
dans votre raisonnement.
Mais... oui...
-Dans un musée ?
-Oui, je pense
que dans l'archétype
des Trente Glorieuses.
Mais là, il y a vraiment...
L'enjeu de la souveraineté, c'est la
résilience. A la fois il nous faut
diminuer nos émissions de carbone,
préserver notre biodiversité,
il nous faut aussi
commencer à nous adapter
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui, ça fait
partie des politiques
qui nous manquent. Plus que
de souveraineté,
nous avons besoin de résilience
et de politiques publiques
de résilience.
-Bien. On arrive
à la fin de cette émission.
Je voudrais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Alors, Jean Jouzel, vous avez publié
"Climat, itinéraire d'un pionnier",
éditions Ouest France,
un entretien avec Paul Goupil.
Vous vous considérez toujours
comme un pionnier ?
-Je sais pas, c'est vrai
que j'ai une certaine antériorité,
mais je travaille sur ces domaines
depuis plus de 50 ans.
Je sais pas si on les a faits
avancer suffisamment rapidement.
-Alors, Magali Reghezza-Zitt, vous
avez écrit avec Stéphanie Beucher
"La géographie: pourquoi ?
Comment ?". Vous n'avez pas
le sentiment qu'on parle
beaucoup de géographie.
Avant, on parlait
beaucoup d'histoire.
La géographie est venue
rééquilibrer un peu le terrain ?
-J'espère ! On y travaille.
C'est une très belle discipline.
Je pense qu'on a aussi
besoin d'histoire.
C'est aussi dans l'histoire...
C'est très dur aujourd'hui
d'expliquer
que nous ne connaîtrons plus
le climat que nos parents,
que nous-mêmes, on a connu petits.
Ca fait bizarre de se le dire.
-Sandrine Rousseau,
vous avez publié,
mais il y a déjà un moment,
avec Adélaïde Bon,
"Par-delà l'androcène".
Vous croyez qu'il y a quelque chose
au-delà de l'androcène ?
-J'espère bien, oui.
J'espère bien.
-Vous y mettez quoi,
des petits hommes verts ?
-Non, j'y mets une société
de coopération, d'égalité,
de résilience
et de sobriété.
Ce serait une société
bien plus heureuse
que de courir
après une chimère.
-Jean de Kervasdoué,
vous avez publié
avec Henri Voron, "Pour en finir
"avec les histoires d'eau".
Récemment, vous avez publié
un ouvrage sur la santé,
mais ces histoires d'eau,
ça vous titille toujours ?
-Non et après, j'ai écrit
"Les écolos nous mentent".
-Il y a
un petit truc obsessionnel
quand même chez vous.
-C'est pas obsessionnel,
mais c'est ancien. C'est ma passion
pour l'écologie qui me conduit
à critiquer l'écologie politique.
-Merci. Je vous remercie,
mesdames, messieurs, d'avoir
participé à cette émission. Merci
à l'équipe de LCP et avant
de nous quitter, je vous soumets
cette pensée : "L'homme énergique
"et qui réussit,
c'est celui qui parvient
"à transformer en réalité
"les fantaisies du désir." C'est
de qui d'après vous ?
-Aucune idée.
-J'ai choisi exprès un auteur
pour mettre en perspective
ce débat.
C'est de Sigmund Freud.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA